[Music]
black mirror Bandersnatch now not only
gives you the ability to make bad
choices for yourself but also someone
else when watching the show you might
feel like dr. strange trying to go
through every possible scenario in order
to find the best one so but those who
haven't got 5 hours to spare in order to
work through every version of Stefan's
journey I decided to break down every
possible ending for the new black mirror
event I pieced this together from a
breakdown posted online which shows
every outcome and through working some
myself there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything and then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay the first possible ending
comes once the fan accepts a job at
Tucker soft and is forced to work in a
team and rush out his dream Bandersnatch
receives zero stars from the best stress
critic in the game and forces Stefan to
defiantly say I'm starting again this is
most likely the ending that the majority
of people will come across it's a good
little one that pretty much informs
viewers exactly how the show will work
early on the broken computer the broken
computer ending comes when Stefan has
the choice to either yell at his father
or pour tea over his computer people who
can't be bothered to go any further can
just tip the tea destroying the computer
and then rekindle the relationship
between Stefan and his father which
doesn't involve chopping him to pieces
after you murder him which we'll get
into later but it's quite a nice little
happy ending isn't it you did the right
thing well don't you the jump the next
available ending comes when you follow
Collin instead of going to therapy
Collin will offer you LSD but either way
this doesn't really make a difference if
you decide not to take it the character
spikes you anyway and discusses the
alternative realities that exist before
offering you a chance to tell him to
jump off the building or to kill
yourself killing yourself ends the story
and Bandersnatch gets finished without
the character medication the next
available option comes when Stefan is
given pills by his therapist most
viewers probably decided to flush these
but those who didn't we'll see if
flash forward to Christmas West a fan
seems slightly happier
he's been on medication for months and
the game was released on schedule
however the best dress critic in the
game decides to give it just 2.5 stars
after stating that it seems like the
Creator was an autopilot which is what
happened to me a bit when I fell asleep
during my third watch through and just
let the choices play out themselves and
now they're broken computer those who
flush the pills will be given another
chance to destroy the computer that I'm
sure many will avoid if they decide to
smash it up like you should smash the
like button on this video though they'll
be treated to another ending that ends
the show pretty abruptly similar to the
one before
Netflix ending yeah one of the best
settings you can get is when you choose
to tell Stefan that he's actually in a
black mirror episode on Netflix doing so
will send the character quite crazy and
make him realise that he's being
controlled wait what if we are in a show
now that is about controlling someone
else on TV and it is actually Netflix
that are controlling us anyway doing
this will send the character back to
therapy in which the therapist notes
that if this was a TV show and it would
be a pretty boring one that doesn't need
to be three hours long she promised
Stefan for some action and this can go
either one of two ways you can either
fight her and then your father which
leads to you being taken away or you can
opt a jump out of the window doing the
latter will completely shatter the
fourth wall and we get the reveal that
Stefan is in fact an actor that is just
doing an episode of black mirror the
director states that the window jump
wasn't scripted and a medic gets called
due to Stefan's injury wait what if
we're still in the episode now no the
murderer ending with Stefan now aware
that he is being controlled he gets the
feeling that someone is driving him to
murder his father similar to the way
that Jerome F Davies was driven to
murder his wife several finales end up
with Stefan in jail for killing his dad
with some leading to his game being
widely received as a 5 out of 5 and
others getting negative
there was a special ending that I got
that surahs leap forward and take charge
of Colin's daughter in present day who
has been tasked with recreating
Bandersnatch this controversial move is
an update on Stefan's recreation of the
book and could ultimately lead to pearl
becoming a murderer too however after
she discovers Stefan trapped within the
code reliving his choices she decides to
destroy the computer ending the show the
Train ending this is arguably the best
ending you can get and it's slightly
similar to the original final scene from
the film the butterfly effect in this
Stefan goes back in time to when he was
a child and manages to retrieve his toy
from his father's safe with the password
pitarrio
Stefan is then given the choice to go
with his mother or not and if he does
then he dies on the train with her - it
turns out that she was always meant to
be on that train and that's the fan
didn't actually delay her like he
thought we then flashback to the present
deceased a fan died in his therapist's
share after fixing the biggest mistake
of his life
so what ending did you get and what did
you think of the show comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of all the choices I made
and my first run-through which will be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you liked you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace man I wish when I was watching
infinity war I had it got thought to aim
for the head why did I choose the chest
No
[Music]
you